herr laschet jetzt ist wahlkampf und
hierbei bild live da bekommen sie harte
fragen wir haben viele zuschauer befragt
und ich möchte mit einem thema beginnen
das auch gerade hier an der wand in den
umfragen zu sehen war da ging es um
patriotismus und die frage ob man ihnen
das als eigenschaft zu schreibt da gab
es nur 4,9 prozent deswegen dachten wir
uns bringen wir direkt am anfang des
gesprächs in etwas mit und zwar hier
eine deutschlandflagge wenn ich ihnen
die mal so einfach übergeben darf
also sie sind ok mit der
deutschlandsberger da gab es ja diese
szene auf die wir gleich noch mal
eingehen werden mittels angela merkel
und hermann groer die will ich ihnen
einmal noch mal zeigen denn da ging es
um die frage nach dem wahlsieg 2017 da
hatte hermann gröhe eine flagge in der
hand und dann am ende ja hat angela
merkel diese flagge weggenommen würden
sie das jetzt kanzler auch machen also
ich glaube sie wollte das rennen
parteiamt und staatsamt aber ich muss
ihnen sagen ich bin groß geworden zu
einer zeit als man so in den 80er jahren
deutschlandfahnen relativ wenig sah bei
fussballspielen ab und an aber nicht so
begeistert wie das heute der fall ist
haben sie eine zu hause an
nein nein ich habe keine zu hause aber
an vielen orten habe ich sie aufhängen
lassen als minister zum beispiel früher
in den ministerien keine fahnen habe ich
auch die deutschlandfahne mit aufhängen
lassen also sie haben danach wenn es das
geht ja da muss ich leute ihr habt alle
nationen feiern beim fußball mit ihren
fahnen und wir sind da zurückhaltend
dann kam 1990 die wiedervereinigung
und dann haben viele menschen plötzlich
deutschlandfahnen gehabt und dann ist
das selbstverständlicher geworden und am
schönsten einer kallmuth wird sich
wahrscheinlich noch daran erinnern wm
2006 da haben die leute einen
begeisterten patriotismus erlebt und ich
war ja mal integrationsminister wir
haben manche
zugewanderten türkischen jugendlichen
gesagt ja ihr sagt immer wir sollen auch
deutsche werden wir sollten stolz darauf
sein aber ihr seid es ja selbst nicht
und die haben dann wie alle anderen
deutschlandfahnen geschwenkt und das ist
das symbol der zusammengehörigkeit
dafür steht einigkeit und recht und
freiheit die rechte nutzen schwarz-rot
also schwarz weiß rot die alte fahne die
eben nicht die deutschlandfahne ist und
deshalb habe ich ein wirklich
freudiges entspanntes verhältnis zu
schwarz-rot wollen noch einmal ganz kurz
zeigen wie das war 2007 die kanzlerin
mit hermann gröhe sie sind auch im
hintergrund zu sehen glaube ich dann
nimmt sie die fahne weg damit herr
laschet wenn sie gewinnen soll diese war
da wohl jemand mit deutschland-flagge
raus was daraus werden darf man auch
deutschland fahne sei also sie
versprechen hier deutschland flaggen bei
einer möglichen wahl wenn man derart
gerne denn es geht um deutschland dafür
machen wir das alles weil wir unser land
in eine gute zukunft führen wollen und
insofern freue ich mich dass ich jetzt
hier liegt
[Musik]